se asoma un posible nuevo golpe para la
economía estadounidense este viernes a
medianoche vence el plazo para que
ferroviarios y los sindicatos que
representan a unos 60.000 trabajadores
lleguen a un acuerdo sobre mejores
condiciones laborales de lo contrario se
iniciaría una huelga en el sector una
que amenaza con ser la mayor en 30 años
una nueva contingencia para el gobierno
de Joe biden
vamos a ser muy sinceros un cierre
tendría un tremendo impacto en nuestras
cadenas de suministro como todos ustedes
saben va a tener un efecto dominó en
nuestra economía en general en las
familias estadounidenses un cierre no es
aceptable no es algo que queramos se
corre el riesgo de perjudicar a las
familias a la agricultura a las empresas
y a comunidades enteras
el presidente editó la huelga hace dos
meses al imponer un período de Gracia
para encontrar una mediación los
ferroviarios aceptaron 8 de 13
recomendaciones del gobierno Pero los
sindicatos que representan a los
ingenieros y conductores piden modificar
las políticas de asistencia y las
condiciones de trabajo
en lugar de bloquear la cadena de
suministros negando los envíos y dejando
potencialmente sin trabajo a nuestros
integrantes el próximo viernes los
ferrocarriles deberían trabajar para
lograr un acuerdo justo que nuestros
integrantes sus empleados ratificarían
de concretarse la huelga podría generar
graves perturbaciones en los suministros
de comida y combustible además de todo
tipo de mercancías se estima que la
huelga costaría unos 2000 millones de
dólares al día pero el congreso podría
intervenir ya sea obligando a un acuerdo
a las dos partes o extendiendo el actual
periodo de Gracia